life on the road it shows taco tangra
course refrigerating guns and these
fight scheduled flights running with the
runs don't blacklist bounced checks
great a bachelorette phones in the front
making out for your side and headlights
doing no more missing merchant tried the
rental car has another megachurch Tim
juice keys vagina Pfister cellphone is
gone one big law and order marathon
we just go ahead and talk about that
right now give me a mic Chucky when I
checked before we left my check one
check check check check what do you
think this will drop by the way at
tonight oh sweet yeah yeah there you ok
hey thanks for tuning road stories
everybody Xhosa Murray valeriano part of
the All Things Comedy Network if you
haven't checked out all things coming to
go check it out there's a lot of great
comics over there uh one of which is
with me today IE are you you're so part
of all things go right ok are you a
funny comic that's what I'm a desk oh
right um alright Graham Elwood needs no
introduction thanks for coming over i
always appreciate when you do sir matt
as much as i see you i still don't see
you enough I know isn't that sweet that
just means we're not surfing enough yeah
man that's what that means yes it does
seeing each other a lot it means we're
surfing a lot yes great thing after
swells and warm weather and we got a ton
of swell coming in over the next two
weeks are you down I go to Lake Tahoe on
Wednesday Oh your ski yeah all right
well that's I'll give you that yeah I'll
give you that um alright a couple things
why Barry Graham you can follow along
with this I've been alright ok so I've
been super busy and not only have I been
busy i got booked like last-minute two
weekends ago and then i got a writing
gig so are my podcast was late so I
apologize for that but it's a great
episode jimmy pardo it's mike siegel
we're still if you buy any if you buy my
album if you buy t-shirts the money's
going to park casteth on this year you
have till Saturday March fit I think is
that what's come at much better myself
yeah that's when they're doing it you
have till then and so the money is going
to go to that and every year we do that
and you guys are great for doing it
every year and I always I don't take
credit for it I put it in under the road
stories listeners I don't take your
money just like Murray so keep on doing
that and then the following week I ended
up going to the dentist and having teeth
pulled and braces so this is my first
podcast with braces I don't know if you
can hear anything going on in my face
what do you look I don't usually you're
like like keys rattling I don't know if
I'm if if I'm listening or whatever I
did do a show the other night
my first stand-up show with braces went
fine I spit all over the front row but I
always do what about this what why did
this stage your life did you go you know
I'm gonna go brace I'd go I like to say
twenty percent vanity and eighty percent
uh orthodontic but my wife says sixty
percent vanity and I think she's being
alike well are today ok it's 84 it's
ninety percent vanity and ninety-seven
percent man and then the guy needed the
money um you're worth Adonis was like
Marie I'm gonna do you mind getting
braces for me oh sure ok if it helps you
out on your family Jay I just um I never
let my way I never got my wisdom teeth
pulled so just shoved everything and
everything's kind of grown all over each
other and it's been a long time coming i
should have done it about 10 years ago
Craig but um why not I also bought
clippers and my wife is cutting my hair
now so I'm living the life of a
nine-year-old I little I watched my
hairdresser last and I call her a
hairdresser she got fired from Fantastic
Sams um and it's in the back of a
warehouse no lie um weird wait a minute
hold on where are you finding this hair
I would a Hair Club I hair Fight Club
it's a one-person club i used to i found
this when i first moved to town I went
to Fantastic Sams and found that well I
initially found one woman who cut my
hair really well and then we went out on
a date and that didn't go well so I'd to
find another one you can't date your
hairdresser and then I found this other
old really nice old old Russian woman at
fantastic sams over on third and she got
fired um but then she resurfaced and
text him he's like I have my own space
now come come back and get your hair cut
i'm like sweet she cuts my hair so great
then it ended up being on lacienega
south of the 10 in a warehouse where
there's like the Russian mafia is
running dog fighting oh yeah there this
is a tax shelter whatever this
whatever's going on during yeah
so it's like just think of a die-hard
take a die-hard all the levels where
where the the party wasn't going on
that's what it looks like and it except
for in the far corner there's a mirror
propped up against the wall leaning and
a chair and a hairdryer and clippers
which I found out you could buy an
Amazon so I'm like I watched her cut my
hair for 10 I'm like you know what I
think I can do this cuz I usually kind
of clean it up myself and I get home so
uh so then what you just have your wife
clean up your neck and them around the
ears basic though my wife does the whole
thing just we're taught this is des type
right here buddy this is yesterday wow
this is yesterday so uh yeah so my wife
enjoyed it was kind of therapeutic I
think just has she ever done any sort of
hairdressing or anything no she she
started cutting my my son's hair and uh
she's not that good at it so I but she
uses scissors not Clippers so I like
definitely go after my head yeah it's my
son my son looks like a special needs
child may be so [ __ ] his dad maybe
that's a look I should go for but but I
figured but I did a lot of research I
didn't just jump into this willy nilly
all right I i watch sure that you say
that you know you can buy clippers on
amazon no really marie but this stuff
you can buy on like you could buy
anything on amazon do not hey just
because i do my homework doesn't mean
you have to look down on me okay i'm
sorry you're still paying twenty dollars
to get a haircut when in two haircuts
mine start paying for itself well if i I
don't I wouldn't trust I see the
financial reward on that sure I do if I
knew someone that I could I found this
woman in a Vietnamese nail salon not ten
years ago racist okay did you buy her is
that what you're saying no I mean every
single person that works there is
Vietnamese and they own it okay and it's
very obvious when you walk in there
they're all talking in Vietnamese ok so
and I say that because I would never
have any reason to go into a place I
don't get my nails yeah why are you
going into nails were you with your
girlfriend or no I was walking down the
street near I live and I
move from the valley to sit I had it I
got a back way out I rear backup I had I
was a guy that always went to old man
barbershops ok and found a guy when I
was living in Chicago that was great
there was a guy and I would like when I
went to college in Arizona I found a guy
with the El Rancho barber shop in Tucson
great shop over there come out saves our
sponsor but don't grab said hi um I
found a guy in Chicago and when I moved
to LA I just couldn't there's no like
old man barbarous they're hard to find
right so I go to these salons and I just
bopped around I mean for eight years it
was like I never had like I'd find
someone and they'd be good and then they
would you know whatever sure so i'm in
santa monica there was an old man barber
shop in Santa Monica and I went there
but the guy was like a thousand years
old his hands were starting to shake no
I it made me nervous yeah yeah and then
one you know I was getting some of his
racist like they gotta let gays get
married that you know I was like all
right I cancers this Vietnamese tow
place down the street but you know a
bunch of Chinamen or fixing your feet
like they're from co real yeah it's a
Vietnam actually sir whatever say so I
was like I gotta find new so I'm walking
down a main street in santa monica and I
see this and they're like men's haircuts
like 18 bucks and I'm like all right
well I don't know what else to do and
this woman this is like Angela Johnson's
bit from her el reloj that's hilarious
the name is Tammy that's my the woman
who cuts my hair that's the name of the
woman in Angela Johnson's bit so if you
go to Angela Johnson probably youtube or
whatever you see that Vietnamese nail
salon lady she's been doing that that
that's the thing that broke her out
right yes they actually talked about
that in last episode um and so I went in
there and this woman Tammy doesn't pick
a lot of English cut my hair perfectly
and I was like well let's see if this
was a one off cuz that's the other thing
I go to people and they would change it
like just to say yeah that's it like
dude what you did last night last time
yes dang do that my head hasn't changed
yeah so she did it every she's been
cutting my hair perfectly Fi
and great and I just can't you know I
can't I'm afraid to run away from it no
I understand that's why I stuck with
this woman me when he hears got 20 years
I know and and I was funny like there
was another girl that worked in there
that this is like before I got married
i'm single and she flirt with me a lot
and I thought about while I could maybe
and I went if this goes south I gotta
get a new I can't haircuts I can't I
can't do it yeah so I was like I'm not
even gonna mess with someone that works
with my hairdresser because I don't want
to mess this up no no good call learn
from my mistakes yeah that's why I'm
here I'm here to teach then you're
having some gypsy cut your head off not
a chop shop you know what I mean like
it's a weird thing you know is that what
was the what was the cutting point that
the tourney not the turning point for me
was when we were in this empty and she's
still there too i have a matter of fact
i have to break the news to this poor
woman that I'm no longer coming to her
to her salon I used quotes she's in
there cuttin my hair halfway through
Clippers electricity goes out just goes
out so we had to go down on the next
floor where all the workers were working
and I'm in the hallway in this bright
pink bib getting my haircut as all these
like you know construction workers are
working walking by me like hey how you
doing just getting my hair cut just
leave me alone so I'm like all right I
think I can do this i watch for a long
time I took down the numbers of the
Clipper sighs she uses and and all that
what do you use it to three on the side
aight i would go nine but they didn't
have nines and this one I think a nine
is an aftermarket by aha anybody got any
black market knives out there listening
cinema Maria where we can I know where
get rid of them so that's what's been
going on my life it's been very hectic
we're back on schedule I apologize for
you to you guys for just kind of the
weird weird schedule we had going on but
we're back on schedule again and I'm
happy to be here and what we're doing
today is we're gonna do something a
little different the other day I was
driving down to the brea improv and I
thought I was thinking about my next
episode and I'm like you know what I
never I don't really involved the
listeners much lately and so I just
threw up on Facebook just haphazardly
hey if you
a question for a comedian they've always
wanted to ask posted here on facebook
and I thought maybe I get one or two I
think last night was like 35 with a half
an hour so I haven't read him haha I
haven't read any of these questions and
uh and so I was gonna do it myself I was
going to drive back from Brian and do it
myself but I thought you know now let me
get it let me get another comedian in
here and let's answer these questions
and I thought who do I want and I
thought well who do I have the most fun
with who do I who do I loved riffin with
and hanging out with and so I called
Graham and so Graham thank you so much
for coming and doing this and letting me
spring this on you cuz I joke was gonna
be so I called this one guy he wasn't
available Graham happens to live close
so I would have liked that I you know
what it's not the first joke the
comedians do it's the second thought
that's what separates us from the layman
maybe I should have called someone maybe
I should have called Chris Mancini all
right so these are I put this on fit now
I got to find it and I'm going off my
phone here so I literally i ah let me
see there's oh I posted the video for
the art of noise closer to the Edit you
should look that up that's good nice
thank you uh what's going on grand while
I figure while my phone loads what has
been going on um comedy film nerds Chris
Mancini myself that's our podcast for
those of you don't listen check it out
it's on iTunes and comedy filmous.com
you're doing alive I don't know by the
time people get this it might be too
late it's gotta be too late but tell
them anyway cuz you you could do it
later okay the great thing so we're
gonna do a live Oscars commentary only
at rabble dot TV um so if you have but
for the fans listening after the fact by
the time you're hearing this their
Oscars are probably done but it will be
archived so let's say you didn't watch
the Oscars but you recorded it your DVRs
sure ya do be art it you could go back
and watch it and then listen to chris
man seen and i do commentary where it's
going to be a lot of us making fun of
the academy right so if you go to rabble
TV Rab ble yeah dot TV not TV or word /
um there is a whole thing for CFM but
just go to rabble that team i'm gonna
type in comedy film nerds oscars and
you'll get it okay
this is gonna be a tight up so because
we both have I have a fancy shmancy
Oscar party to go to yes and you got
your fancy smancy stuff to go to so
we'll make this a tight one yeah um
actually I have no fancies me actually
I'm going to an Oscar party where a
bunch of people didn't get nominated
they're all gonna be pissy you should
have them on your rabble [ __ ] that guy's
a hack welcome to set decorator Jesus
Christ I can buy that at whole foods oh
great I would love to be at that party I
also i was gonna invite you but then I
saw you're doing the rabble thing so I
couldn't do that i'm still scrolling
down well i posted a lot of stuff on
facebook i just realized oh here we are
quick do you have a question you'd like
to ask a comedian leave your question on
the comment section to it fast we're
recording shortly four days later uh
alright 20 wow what divinity yeah we got
about 29 comments ok all right there we
go 20 all right uh from mark clean a guy
went to high school with nice i'm coming
to LA can i sleep on your wife I mean
couch [ __ ] you I was stupid yeah that
was that was that was not good he said
I'm only kidding i'm a comedian not with
that joke you're not ok let's go to exit
this is from listener Daryl Asher I bet
he's a comedy film nervous man yes
definitely a podcast fan true or false
mosphere better comedians cut their own
hair Steve Martinez cut his hair for
years that's not without to the top
Seinfeld same thing oh we were talking
about we're talking about me cutting
cutting my hair I'm the last episode
because I was going to buy the Clippers
and I've had conversations with Darryl I
sure could have been better timing
Darryl on that question that was
hilarious question uh I said this last
time Jake Johansen still uses the
flowbee uses a flowbee bill to this day
I think he's talking about it on this
show wow that's where you hook your
vacuum ya up to the Clippers I
understand what if you added that up
he's probably saved like 20 grand or
something over the years I think he's
got a nice house and Santa Monica it's
not comedy money no he does the opposite
of what Leno does and I don't use my
stand-up money i use my hair saving
money my hair cutting money all right
Andrew rich listener uh what's your
favorite George Carlin bit that's
interesting that's a good for me
it would have to be the baseball
football one yeah that's my favorite one
that makes sense as I love both of those
sports and I love his take on uh-huh you
know football's on baseball's just that
like I just love that bit um I don't
know I my favorite joke he ever did was
uh he's talking about the word [ __ ]
and he's like [ __ ] doesn't mean what
it means today when I was a kid I'm
completely butchering this when I was a
kid a [ __ ] was a guy who wouldn't go
downtown and beat up the queers with you
that's a great job yeah I got it I know
I told the story a thousand times but I
I worked the door at the comedy store
when he was working out his one of his
specials and that was amazing to watch
right because from Monday and he did
like six nights in a row and he came out
with notes and like a church table and
watching it from Monday to how it
evolved by saturday was it wasn't like
he did a set went home went to bed went
to the gym the next day came home did it
again no you went home rewrote
everything came back tried in a
different way moved it all around it was
pretty cool to watch that's gotta be
impressive that was a night where I had
to walk I walk after a chance to walk
him out to the parking lot there's a
hallway in the back of the comedy store
and you're looking at my braces aren't
you you're staring right at all just
stare right out you're the worst oh god
no you don't look fat in those pants
Murray you look pretty I have put on a
couple pounds Oh shot so I'm walking
George Carlin out the hallway and just
for some reason that day Gallagher
stopped in just completely out of the
blue Gallagher stopped in and as we're
walking out I look on stage in the
original room and it's a Willie Tyler
and Lester and then we walk out to the
parking lot and Franklin Ajay is there
and I'm like is this 1988 weird time
warp did I go hey there's the unknown
comic there's a Sandra Bernhardt like
it's let's get crazy I worked with the
unknown comic down at the comedy magic
club years back and I he he came out as
the unknown comic but nobody believed he
was the unknown comic like I was just a
guy doing the unknown comic thing and I
thought what a weird kind of
earn his career because first he was the
unknown comic froze II don't know the
unknown comic was a comedian who wore a
paper bag over his head who ice to dress
up as Halloween as the unknown comic in
school and first time I ever saw him was
a kid on the gong show I was a garnish I
think I so much shona now was the first
time I saw we are not dating ourselves
at all right TV shows sha-na-na and the
gong show the gong show was amazing the
gong show was so much fun it was so it
was one of the I think there's several
things that I point2 influencing my
becoming a comedian uh-huh my whole
family sitting around listening to Steve
Martin records okay the when Saturday
Night Live first hit because saturday
with Friday center is the only night i
could stay up late okay and watching the
gong show and sitcoms like i'd watch
sure sure worse yet but the gong show
was where I was like oh this is just
comedy is just this since like the whole
cocktail party vibe of so many TV shows
from the 70 right yeah Hollywood Squares
and match game we're just like oh these
are rich people Hollywood people just
getting boozed up and um and I love the
gong show and that's where I met that's
why I saw the unknown comic and yeah I
loved it when he came out mhm mhm one
time he was like hey let me show you
pictures of my kids and then throughout
smaller bags Oh malarious like the first
time I ever went on today I guess you
can call this my first stand-up was it a
talent show at my dad's church and I
went on as the unknown comic and my
opening joke was and I kind of thought
of this in years I put my bag over my
head and I cut out the eyes then I put a
plastic bag over my head and said you
probably don't recognize me had plastic
surgery no that's a great job sixteen
buddy that's an exchange Jim I not more
famous haha it turns really dark of
course ah uh thanks Darla oh no that
wasn't Daryl a sure that was uh who's I
Andrew rich Bernadette bats you know
Bernadette I know I love Bernadette
remember Bernadette she wrote it's great
i did a million shows with her she wrote
who runs that room such a non sequitur
but perfect comedian question explain
who runs at room graham the who runs
room joke is something that any time a
comic is talking about some gig another
comic will go who books that cuz where I
trying to hustle to get work so it's
it's common thing we've all said it and
I said it last night sure what the
improv it was talking to Laurie
Kilmartin t-shirt the embroidery come
Martin was on the show she writes for
Conan I was like hey who books the
comics on Conan right oh here's the guys
address so oh good um physical address I
gotta show up at his house that's
awesome you cut your own hair um so um
so then for comedians then when somebody
says something horrible or like God I
had this awful gag it was in a thing a
comic will then make the joke books that
yeah yeah that was laughs it's like a
content we all make that joke but it's I
still it's one of those jokes it's so
inside but I love it I love making it I
love hearing it I love that she put it
on that that's mass for your questions
who books that gig that's why I love
comics and Bernadette makes me laugh and
you can tell that the shallower of the
comic because when they drop that when
they seriously drop that line because
you could be like oh man I had to set of
my life I was at the improv last night
you know JP from the conan was there and
i think my life's good books that you
know like she just completely miss oh
man i had the worst night of my life I'm
really thinking about getting out of the
business I don't understand and don't
book saticons yeah they're not listen
your straight leg yeah her gig hey and
who books that yeah yeah there's three
question there's a gig where's the gig
it pays and who books it mm-hmm exactly
that's the thing so you answered the
first two with the night you almost
killed yourself that comedy condo okay
des moines and it's cash they put you up
yeah dinner there was a great i saw an
interview with an astronaut one time and
i can't remember who it was but they're
doing like a town hall and somebody
raised their hand and said where do you
go to the bathroom and he said
guy who mentored me as a astronaut said
you can always tell the level of
maturity by how early that question
comes in the if you answer all the other
scientific questions first and then
weird about then you're good but if
you're starting off with where'd he go
to the bathroom it's all downhill from
there that's hilarious I usually like to
open with uh did we really land on the
moon yeah that's one stop your lies yeah
just start with that one man I wish
there's a side of me I'm not a
conspiracy theories but there is a side
of me that really wishes we didn't land
on the moon I may I would love the
ultimate [ __ ] prank on everybody
right dag come on I'm not calm prevailed
was impressive making the Statue of
Liberty disappear but I'm definitely an
astronaut file ah so the landing on the
moon i think is awesome how do you
explain the Van Allen ring of radiation
around the earth the Van Allen ring of
radiation around the earth so what is
that theory that is we have a radiation
ring I believe it's the Van Allen ring
of radiation around the earth and that
nothing can get through it because
you'll just melt so that is the reason
why we've never sent anybody to the moon
like all the plan because you can't get
through the I can't get through the
ringer radiation according to some dude
I saw on PBS oh okay it's baby ass well
I just wanted and he kept saying hey put
on a suit and drop yourself in a hot
nuclear reactor in and I'll shut up like
that was this whole thing right and
nobody ever really did that yet I don't
think well that's an interesting theory
I think he's a winged bird oh and like I
said there's too many people involved mm
for it to be a conspiracy if it was a
conspiracy there's way too many people
involved for there not to be someone
inside NASA one of the astronauts going
come on there's no there's no way plus
the the whole like I've seen the well
look at the how could they do this right
right how come the flag yeah yeah is
well there is some atmosphere on the
moon and things do move a little so you
are going to see that happen sure you
know where the shadows well if the Sun
was
shining right now there is like I and
and I love the fact that you know buzz
aldrin punch one of those guys in the
mouth once shut him up he was letting
all the secrets out I think so i think i
think if you're Alan Turing radiation
but it's always saying all right if
you're guilty you backpedal oh yeah you
don't you don't punch a guy in the mouth
shut up oh yeah I guess you'd bring more
attention to it yeah if you punch a guy
no maybe like all know but I know with
lemon I that you backpedal you know
that's the training mmm that's where the
training come all of them all of them
we're trained although now is I think
Japan is scheduled to put somebody in
the mood within the next six years and
will know because we left a bunch of
[ __ ] up there so if it's not there then
we'll know how okay but will shed a
little little anything it'll shut at
least all this cuz maybe Canada it's
kinda dunno cuz we've already been up
there a bunch but thats So You Think and
not a bunch we've been in outer space a
bunch we haven't been to the moon a
bunch ah we all we did 11 we did 12 a
bunch we did 14 Apollo 11 12 and four
today land yeah they did yeah that's
part of the theory is why I remember
watching one of these debunk that it
didn't happen Jeff and they interviewed
the these guys that were like whoa how
can we never went back and then they go
to NASA's like what do you talk about 12
it just wasn't as covered as much are
they picking up these guys at a bar like
get some guys who've done their research
like I have sure been Ailin during
irradiation what I've read even sure
that's the name of it the van Halen ring
of radiation ladies and job why didn't
they named their album ring a radiation
it's the running with the devil ring of
radiation all right Darrell Asher's back
for round two let's hope this is a
legitimate question hi Bernadette by the
well hi Bernadette I'm just gonna see
Brenda tonight at this party all night
it's just a weird series of coincidences
we're going to she'll be read with kids
and everything took me to me Michael
bats aha and we're going with a
executive producer my wife works with a
lot that were really good friends with
just half their kids go to the same
preschool is Bernadette scale see
Bernadette Lee open
I said hello what's your this is darrell
Asher again what's your go-to joke when
audience when the audience is getting
away from you and a two-parter and our
street jokes fair game in such desperate
circumstances good question I don't
necessarily have a go-to when the
audience is I don't have like a line
that I use it right when audience is
getting away and they're not paying
attention to their talking I usually go
right at them go right at the table
that's not talking yeah make fun of them
um Street jokes you know i'm not a big
proponent of street jokes but I feel
like if your back is against the wall
like hacking someone to get out of a
situation that's [ __ ] right that's
[ __ ] but a street joke I mean if
that's what you gotta do to survive like
your emceeing you know a late show I
mean ice that's you know or if you're in
vegas and you got it you know you're the
MC in the crowd stiff or not there that
they're [ __ ] around and not paying
attention there are still talking in on
their phones and they're not taking the
MC seriously and the i mean i did this
way back when I used to MC I mean
sometimes I would do the you know oh man
what's your birthday uh oh I'm not gonna
ask hold er that's rude how much do you
weigh I mean that a thousand years sure
people showing up late can I get you
something like a watch yeah yeah those
are a million years old I wouldn't call
it a street jokes though no I also kind
of staple would come staples no not yeah
they're not Street jokes but they're
definitely like a you know old comic
sure sure crutches right right I know
what you'd call them i would put them in
the same category as a street joke
personally ok if you have I don't you
know I don't know that I I'm not gonna
look down on someone that does that has
to do a street joke in that situation I
look down on people that are doing
Street jokes in their act oh yeah it's
just part of the rack then I'm like you
have no business being up there yeah and
it's usually some dude who hasn't
written a new dude like right now I
followed a guy like they did if I've
talked about this last week I follow the
guy i did a benefit in the opener was
just all street jokes and then closed
with Keenen Ivory Wayans best joke
oh man Wow umm i umm i agree with you i
don't have anything I don't have a go-to
I do what you do I just address the
situation and just figure out what's
going on but there was a comic on here
and I forget who it was who said hey if
you're an Idaho and you're her you're
just tanking and you're you're getting
crickets and you need my golf bit go for
it yeah it's gonna save you go ahead
just call me up and tell me you did it
that's all I ask I I have some I don't
have street jokes but I have some stock
my stock like going into my old
inventory of just like dick jokes that I
know cuz usually a dick joke or an
f-bomb will get their attention yeah and
I've had to do that where I'm just like
okay you want this dick joke from 1993
guess what [ __ ] here it is cuz
you're too dumb to get the new tracks
right so yeah not bad I do want a stock
hack joke that i like but i always call
it out when i do it and I'm just like
that's the oldest one in the book I
don't even know why you guys are
laughing at that read a book or
something Casey Murphy always been with
me a long time Casey Thanks for writing
in is the comedy club condo mentioned in
some older stories still a thing or is
that a relic from the 80s and 90s still
a thing and a relic from the 80s and 90s
like from these 90s that is sadly still
a fan it should be gone well yeah but
I'm very excited just found out that
their redo got a great condo down at the
Loya Comedy Store that they're redoing
oh great they're finally redoing that
you know it's a [ __ ] the downtown zanies
in chicago has a studio apartment that's
a block away and i kind of get it
because it's downtown chicago and hotels
are 250 a night sure if it's a crowded
weekend if it's a bit it's three you
know like 190 200 is the cheapest you
can get so I kind of get that and it is
fine i have stayed in it it's fine you
know it's it's in it's a block away and
it's in a cool neighborhood like where
this downtown zanies is and they only do
that for the downtown zanies the one out
in rosemont they put you in a nice hotel
oh really so I think st. Charles they
put you in a nice home also
so it's really just it's not them being
cheap [ __ ] it's them going look we
just don't have it in the budget right
when a big-name act comes in that's
selling out the kosher then of course
that act gets whatever they want but
there's a nice i'm doing a laughs
unlimited sacramento in june and they've
got they bought nice condos oh really
yeah they got one for the middle one for
the headliner and they're decent in
there right across the street and
they're in Old Town Sacramento so you
have all that touristy stuff you can do
that's the other thing too I'm not
sharing I'm not a high school volleyball
team I'm not sharing an apartment with
[ __ ] opening acts I don't like I'm
not right like and I and the clubs that
still do that I mean one club I had a
conversation with the guy and he was
like look it's it's we don't have the
money in this market and I said I go
honestly I go add up all of your costs
with this condo you clean it all the
utilities insurance we all of it now I
add up your hours put a dollar amount on
your per hour wage mm-hmm add all that
up I bet you yeah yeah you know and you
could get some kind of deal with a with
a you know we're talking about a Hampton
Inn sure or some Fairfield by marriott
these are nice you know these are hotels
that are gonna book out 495 a hundred
dollars a night I bet you could get them
down to fifty nine dollars a doubletree
look like a doubletree like a total
champ tannins are amazing yeah I don't
know if I say to the hamsters here's my
thing on Hampton so I I focus on I'm a
big reward miles right waits person so I
focus all my flights on United mm-hmm
and by doing so I get upgraded I just
got upgraded back from Minnesota I get
six international upgrades a year oh
nice I flew [ __ ] first class to
Australia oh that's the only way to go
to Australia yeah yeah I did it to Japan
I don't have money for first those are
$10,000 tickets right I don't have money
for that so and I do that with hotels I
ice focus on Hilton yeah Hilton Marriott
is getting a lot better Hilton's reward
program is very good Nene Hampton Inns
are part of the program and Hamptons are
in every small town really yes
so and here's the thing from the outside
they look very boring mmm but they all
have a free breakfast from six to ten
and it's a full you got you and I are
vegetarian sure yes food we can eat okay
um coffee tea all that stuff uh they all
have it a pool most of them have a pool
and a hot tub right right I swim laps
yeah and all the rooms are very
consistent decent bed nice desk nice
office chair like and you're getting
hilton points so what I do I boom and I
do a gig once a year on Oahu mm-hmm and
the gig pays okay but it's not enough so
I usually like pay for a plane ticket
and then I cash in my Hilton put that
that's my vacation nice yeah that's
great a year of staying at Hampton Inns
by freeways in the Midwest that then
pays for me to stay at the hilton
waikiki for four nights ah and that's
why I think it's that's actually a good
because I know there's a lot of young
comics listening that's a good note pick
an airline and pick a hotel chain and
stay with them that you're gonna eat it
a couple times up front it's gonna be
pricey up front but think long-term man
I'm telling you people say that well
what you know it's it's I love Southwest
I said to Southwest I flew first class
for freeones ununited hmm on a 747 so
first business and coat yeah it was the
Southwest do that no no and I'm telling
you I used so this this gig I just did
in Oahu then my girlfriend and I went to
Maui for four nights I used a hundred
thousand united miles to stay at a
swanky [ __ ] resort mm-hmm worth every
penny sure sure and I'm telling you I do
that with hurts to pick a rental and oh
yeah rental car yeah and I do the same
thing my hawaii trip that i have a free
rental car for four days because a year
of renting cars i tell people that if
you're gonna travel for a living pick
one yeah American United whatever and
stick with it I agree but you brought up
an interesting point jacuzzis I'm a some
people like the other go I don't there's
so much chlorine kills everything right
well here's my question skin we both
work the we both were in
ler in your hair yeah that we both work
the Las Vegas improv yes they have a
nice spot love that spot that jacuzzi
you go naked or you go shorts I go naked
okay cuz it's man only right right I
thought about wearing shorts in there
and I've done that but then I'm just
saying I feel it out you know I usually
am there when there's not like I don't
know there's I'm usually they're like
nine in the morning oh really yeah on
their 12 I go nine empty empty of course
it's Vegas everybody still sleep
everyone still sleep there yeah there's
like one or two people on the treadmill
like the runner yeah crazy runner peach
area and then what I do is you have to
sign in I look and find out where the
comic is Bentley okay gram came in at
nine o'clock this morning i'm good i
don't have to see his weighing in the
jacuzzi because that's really all I just
don't want to do I don't want to see the
other comics penis yeah that's true I
other peoples are fine I know I just
don't want to have to while he's on
stage just go and saw his penis earlier
today funny bit what I saw his penis
knows me but I know it looks like Kerry
toboggan toboggan toboggan my shirts
Robin yeah he booked used to book the
old horn blowers he might still be my
book Hornblower's but i know he booked
uh didn't he book the MGM or no he oh
really we'll catch a right while the
catch clubs oh I booked all the caches I
think so okay all right I thought he was
horn blares by could be wrong you might
do both okay uh I'll say this again
catch a rising star boy that is one
franchise I gone down the [ __ ] man
that should be and that should be up
that should be above the improv of
course that was the place to be in the
70s cash was and the New York club and
that like it was yeah and they had it no
now it's like a one-nighter in a hotel
in Princeton I know it's a shame look at
what the improv is done yeah yeah you
know 30 some clubs across the country or
whatever and they own saw a lot of those
funny bones too right right cat should
be doing that too i know i don't know
what happened so come on Carrie with the
fedora drove it into the ground Carrie
I'm just kidding he's a nice guy do you
ever get nervous now he's being a comic
being an [ __ ] asking us the question
that's a great that's just like
Bernadette's Joe right
cuz that's a question we're always ass
yeah you gave you nervous now you
nervous I can never do what you do it so
I hate when people say oh my god what
you do is so hard I'm like there I don't
know there's so much more harder jobs I
mean it's hard but it's not it's not
hard we have blue diamonds yeah I'm
Laura Laura house did did time last
night at the at the improv and she was
making that joke too she's like really
hard yeah you're right I'm gonna go up
to a coal miner and be like you have no
idea trying to get booked on a gig is
like you know I did just drive through a
construction yeah just those those cats
like even the person holding the stop
and slow sign is that something a fun
easy gig do they get run over get they
get killed it's in the hot sauna it's
freezing I'm Minnesota they're still
doing construction in Minnesota in
February man but I can't get this call
back to work it's just know and it's so
hard to get gigs booked and if you just
yeah I mean show business is hard in the
sense that it's not fair but come on I
always talking to listener Tom Norberg
I'm sick you think I'm saying that right
tom he's also big listener rock solid
and lives up in San Francisco coming up
at a purple honey in there this summer
uh and he's a fireman and I and he would
contacted me on facebook or something
and i was going to vegas and my ass I
guess it's like six nights man it's this
is two shows a night you know I'm kind
of bitching about how hard it was and
then he not joking around was like yeah
I had a rough week also I had to pull
this dead woman out of a burning feel
like the woman we've no like and I'm
like well I'm just a big douche bag what
you should says oh right talk to me when
you do a load show friday i see that
with Ken Jeong uh who now as a sitcom
dr. ken when he before he blew up and
was like I remember like I'd see him at
the improv yeah as a full position and I
be I remember one time inviting I'm like
hey dude I'm having like I had like a
showcase or something can you mind
coming to his like I actually that's
when i work at cancer ward oh and i was
like that was the joke i kept going
alright whatever you do
saying um I have television people
coming to watch me do seven minutes well
he was a full-on doctors just doing
stand-up do we still doing stand-up at
the same time hilarious man used to do
those great wraps oh do is he would tell
me the pressure he was getting because
he came you know he's Korean so there's
this very much like like you're a lawyer
or a doctor and this stand-up comedy his
family was like what oh really like the
only way he could still be doing it is
by blowing up in Todd Phillips movies
you know like there's exactly no way you
could you could he could keep doing or
at least not get pressure unless you're
in like the most successful comedy
franchise holy crap wow wow my parents
gave up on me a long time ago all right
there's you everything about a podcast
yes I still don't know what it is oh
yeah it shows great my friend Suzy
Nakamura plays his uh his wife he's
great who I ran into at comedy but not
heavy Filner it's at the pod fest I
hadn't seen her in like eight years all
real all was great man she's not because
she's awesome she's been a regular she's
written articles for a second emerged
she wrote a couple chapters in our book
mm-hmm and we had her she brought Dave
Foley all right right here the two of
them cuz they're because he's on dr. ken
as well and she Suzy Nakamura makes me
laugh so hard oh yeah I've noticed in
Chicago she's one of the funniest people
oh I didn't realize you guys went way
back that far but yeah I met her she did
second city and all this stuff yes she's
hilarious we met doing an improvised
play back in when I don't know 2000 i
guess it was who's me her Jerry minor I
don't know others named psych isn't
amazing improvise yeah mazing improviser
hilarious actress really sweet girl glad
for both of them yeah so seriously do
you ever get nervous the only time I get
in I get I don't get nervous I mean like
if you're like doing something on TV I
might get a little nervous like just
doing some gig no I get anxious when
it's the it's the type of gig I'm
headlining and when you're headlining
the ticket sales are so important yeah
that that's what I'm like [ __ ] I got
promoted this I tweeted it I was doing I
said on on our pod leg because you know
it doesn't there's clubs I've headlined
where the ticket sales weren't good all
week and it's like yeah now the owner
flat out said man I think you're
hilarious but i gotta i know it stings a
little man i got one from the brea
improv last year I came back to do I
like texted him I wanted to come back
and down like yeah well ticket sales
weren't that good last time like oh I
know but it still hurts that you say it
again I'm like what about the time
before that they were great like yeah
we're only going off the last show I'm
telling you like and I'm on both sides
of it with LA pod fest I've had to tell
comics you know you were in our festival
but you had nine people there oh yeah
you know I'd love i love your podcast I
think it's awesome I think you're
hilarious but we have a [ __ ] huge
budget are you talking to me yeah Marie
this is a this is a tough time to bring
it up but I just I think you got to go
back to paying for haircuts I real a
callback they oh um no but it's like uh
it is it is a thing and it's like being
on the other side of it like losing sure
and knowing and you produce shows
there's a budget there's a reality of
that budget as a performer it will
always sting mm-hmm it's never going to
not stay oh sure the difference for me
now is I don't bellyache as much about
the sting as I used to write because I
just understand the economics of the
business right because I have to tell
this I mean I literally had to say look
I get it I've been told I can't work a
club anymore mm-hmm I'm sorry to have to
tell you this but that's got to ease it
a little bit yeah because the other
person anyway and then and that's why I
like it because that I mean 11 club
owner that said it to me he's really
cool and really straightforward with me
so I the way he said it to me I was like
well that's how I will say it mmm oh
that's cool you know yeah cuz he wasn't
he didn't he didn't just avoid my calls
he didn't just write he said he just
flat out he's real straightforward and I
really respect that about the guy
and and I've started to do some business
with him his company might be doing some
business with pod fast no it was it was
like that's I just as like well that's
how I want to be talked to yeah that's
great you know because you know this
like a long maybe is better a quick no
is better than a long maybe yeah or just
not responding yeah just [ __ ] tell me
know yeah so now I you know what I will
say this is what in what Cody at the
improv in brea told me was like yeah
your numbers weren't that good like I
know he's it but let's work out a liquor
deal maybe we can get Jack and Coke in
here to do it like he wasn't less are
your sales weren't good he knows me
right he knows I can deliver he's like
maybe we can do something together and
bring those numbers back up well that's
what I love because there is there is
especially in this new economy this new
digital whatever and I think the
recession sort of taught a lot of people
like old business models I don't know
yeah and everyone's being more open the
comedy clubs too especially that are
getting podcasts in there and some I
think they're more open to some sort of
because it were like it if it works it
works yeah if the money like we're
businessmen so if you come to me with a
thing that works I'm in sure sure you
know like if you like the person and you
think they're funny and talented and I
on a pain in the ass which those are
important things are definitely
important they're not easy to come by oh
yeah no those are important there is one
guy on the comics on safari tour who is
no longer with us because he was a big
fan yes not worth it I'm friends with
them and we'll surf together and still
do other shows together but I had to say
sorry bud not worth it any means like
all right that's how I am I'm like okay
i'll see you in the water yeah like at
least like cool all right yeah Casey
Murphy and final out two questions I
think it's gonna be our last one we
gotta wrap things up here how are we
doing on time oh we got one or two let's
do one or two here and then I got plenty
more so maybe I'll do this as a part two
in a couple weeks it's great deals great
so to do more of these yeah well I've
apparently used all my 35 fans I need I
need 36 to get into pot fest next year
actually got 18 a bunch of them are
asking twice that's true alright thanks
for noting that [ __ ] I'm not as this
man that's what I all right numbers
don't lie Murray you know i can't pay
[ __ ] rent on this gun Darryl a sure
Casey Murphy if I'm allowed to questions
and you are because you've been with me
since the beginning is there a
competitive attitude between comics when
they do they're set as if laughs were a
commission check for salespeople or is
it more like working together to make
the show roll smoothly I understand the
second half i don't get the Commission
part of that oh I think I understand our
mission thing like are we judge
businessman now you're no longer an
artist I no longer an articles dead I
just want to crush people for a nickel
I'm sorry I'm when I'm in the next tax
bracket with you we can talk Oh believe
me friend yes I I'm not making a lot of
money as this digital entrepreneur yes
um but uh I think I if I understand the
question correctly are we all sitting in
the back of the room like well this
comic got 10 laughs and I only got seven
are we doing that oh yeah I think
there's some comics out there who are I
think we're all competitive you have oh
definitely spent but like I think some
comics are just over the top and their
dicks about it mm-hmm like I think we
all want to have good shows and nobody
wants to follow someone that destroyed
and then eat it right you know so we all
like like like I did a show once at the
Hollywood improv and um Laurie kill I
had Laurie Kilmartin and Baron von on it
and Laurie Kilmartin destroyed she's
[ __ ] funny my show lesson she
destroyed and and baron was watching her
set and he was going next and he was
talking to me he goes dude because I was
gonna try some new [ __ ] uh uh yeah he
goes and it was a packed house was like
valentine's day a year ago right right
and he was like so he had that like that
I but he wasn't like folklore your
anything he's like okay damn she set the
bar high
then he went on stage and destroyed the
audience I think we as comics and get in
our heads but I think the audience isn't
like some audiences are judgmental dicks
pressure but some audiences are just
like let's have fun like we just want to
laugh and have a good time in this comic
was great and this comic was great loved
it and so I prefer putting shows
together where it's everyone is doing
the second part of this question yeah
like everyone wants the overall show to
be great and it's sort of it's sort of
yes to both of these parts of the
question they all want the show to be
great and part of that is well I want my
I want my set to kill sure but I want
everyone else to kill like when we've
done comics on safari I don't want
everyone to eat it and then I have a
great set right because I want the whole
show to be great but I also think
there's two different types of shows
we're talking if we're talking a regular
weekend show opener middle headliner you
everybody wants like having to follow
that guy who did Street jokes and and
headline that last show was like REI got
eight minutes of work to do to get him
so this is what stand-up really is so
I've got to work so you want your
openers to do good because you don't
want to work and you if you're an opener
you want to do good so that they'll they
don't have the headliner doesn't have to
work and they'll bring you back right so
in that situation I think everybody
wants the now when you get to like the
showcase rooms like the improv I think
it's I think I mean I everybody want but
i think it's i think it's a free-for-all
at that point i think it just goes to
who you are you and I want the show the
whole show to be great if we're just
doing a 10 minute slot on it but then
there's other ones who are like I don't
care I want to go after him and write
this or is that yeah and I think it's it
depends on the type of like like when I
and I'm sure it's you this one you know
when the improv lets you headline you
get to pick the lineup right I mean they
might suggest people so when I picked
the lineup i'm picking a line up because
i want everyone to be great because i
have friends and fans coming to the show
and i want them to be like man that
whole show was awesome I like totally
introducing them to new comics mm-hmm
like kira soltanovich did my show once
and everyone loved her and then they
came back when she headlined exactly
that's what i want and last night i did
this this variety show it then it the
lab at the improv
and so again i picked everybody and a
lot of were some acts i hadn't seen in
Jamie who books that suggested them to
me but i really trust his judges and
he's coming from the same place I want
the whole show to be cool and great and
and it's my it's Graham Elwood show so I
want everything to be cool but you're
right on just like some industry
showcase you kind of want the guy to
tank so you can go so you look like you
hit the home run you mean you know
totally that's that's why I'm you know I
have a big improv I went through I oh
and all that stuff background I remember
when I would audition for commercials
and they have improvisers in and you
number one rule for an improvised you
just make your buddy look good right and
that is out the window when it comes to
audition oh it was like you just got
burned on that so many times because I
would be like all right let's team and
then some guy would just be like member
just step on your neck step on anything
and yes and they'd be like wow grandma
have you like I remember saying one
casting director I said god damn it put
me I go you saw me in the lobby joking
around why didn't you teaming up with my
friends yeah yeah definitely we would
have [ __ ] destroyed instead you had
some model actress trying to be funny
just sticking her tits out count like
shut up yes yuck that's glad I don't do
that anymore is great i got a copy deep
because we didn't even get halfway
through this i don't think i got a copy
these and save this is first and we'll
come back and we'll do this again I you
know what I promised you guys a bonus
episode so maybe in the next couple
weeks I'll get somebody else in here and
tackle this again anagram you're
obviously welcome to come back whenever
you want to back i love these questions
yes and this is great so what's going on
with graham what is go home with graham
should have done one more question make
it a long one make it a long answer you
might do another question all right
let's do one more all right let's do one
more now we're gonna go along who's who
is I was at Casey Lauren erlanger how
does your version of the aristocrats go
there's very comedy savvy people they
are seriously man I don't even have an
aversion of aristocrat doesn't know that
I do the Arista but that's a great part
about that documentary haha
when they say the comics version of the
aristocrats gives you a window into who
they knew they really are however they
write that and I was like that was
really that's it because my favorite and
I don't actually have one but my
favorite was before the aristocracy
aristocrats is this long standing joke
which is about being as crude and
horrible and offensive offensive as it's
really a joke for it's a con it's comics
joke right and they did a movie and
what's-his-face he's been on the program
a few times senza Provenza did a
documentary on it and everyone my
favorite one is actually the South Park
one and I'm not even a big south park
fan but they're like you know then he
does his impression of the victims of
911 it's horrible and it's great but my
favorite my all-time favorite one is
windy liebman's friend of the show she's
on there and she just turns it on her
ear she's like they come in a nit they
make tea for everybody oh its name of
your act the goddamn [ __ ] cuts
or something like just really turns it
on her here she's awesome we love Wendy
Liebman sorry that's a little bit too
deep to go into for the last question so
we'll call it there maybe we approach
that one what's going on Graham what is
got Marie V on Twitter yes yes really on
Twitter gonna interrupt with all my
hands like just at Road stories um yes
okay i'll be at the las vegas improv in
june oh oh wait a thing we're gonna I
set you up for another joke I don't have
anything else okay uh yeah so the purple
onion jun 2nd great that's a great game
I haven't done it go excited um Tim Lee
and I are co-headlining now I love San
Francisco oh yeah i'm looking forward to
I love San Francisco um earbuds pop
we're doing a whole run actually Tim and
I went to an all ride we're doing a
purple onion on Thursday then laughs
unlimited and then uh we're locking in
something up there i'll give you her
number she's hard to get ahold of their
great though i love him but she's hard
to get all of it yeah cuz the punchline
they're not giving me any love Holly hey
there my love Molly but yeah give me any
love so I gotta I gotta go across the
streets all right man yeah I'll totally
hook you um
and go ahead i want to interrupt
anywhere but it's a good bit um so
earbuds podcasting documentary is done
oh great we're submitting it to bits
three and a half hours long you know
that's the first part the second part is
another for um no we got it down about
an hour 40 okay great i was about an
hour 45 that we showed it pod fests oh
now me and that was so well received at
pod fest and even even some like I even
knew some bitter people going in there
came out like when I was really good and
I say and I say bitter just you know
sure harden comic card came came out
were just like that was really good
that's good to hear you know that was
the cool part about at that you want to
go back to the do you get nervous
questioning screening a movie that you
directed is the most nerve-wracking
thing on the face of the year really
comedy if the crowd gets [ __ ] like I
have control mm-hmm even though sure the
mic goes out I can yellow like I can get
the train entre if a movie screening is
shitty it's just watching a train slowly
fall off a bridge just dive into it like
there's nothing you can do and I'm so
horrifying but when it is well received
its its is really cool so earbuds is
done it was so cool screening the the
the rough cut at pod fest my hands look
great and you have the best you're the
best podcast hand actor that's out there
I there's got to be a career in that
well you're gonna get nominated um we'll
see you tonight at the party you'll get
nominate well first of all your hands
are white so you got a really good job I
got a good totally good shots so black
where they count so yeah that movie's
done uh and it'll be you know we'll have
it for sale on some capacity by the mall
okay are you gonna do it a pod fest
again this year that's a good question
maybe you should I don't think we should
we believe we shot the wad last year and
you bumped me out of my slot if you
wanted to do road stories against the
most anticipated oh and I appreciate
that but I waited till the opening of
star wars before I did a live one at the
arclight
choice yeah you got good you good good
good stuff out so yeah that'll be an LA
pod fest uh it's a little be in
September at the sofitel where we have
the dates all like they were noun Singh
next week oh great one tickets on sale
next week next week oh this and this is
live too so yeah it's on sale next week
um and we sold out last year yeah great
and we're only releasing a limited
number of we're gonna early bird special
hundred-dollar weekend pass and then if
you don't get it this first round the
price will go up ok so I'm encouraging
people to buy early guys come on I'm
talking to a bunch of listeners who
haven't come out yet I'm looking I'm
looking at this list Casey Murphy why
are you coming down Darryl a sure why
are you coming down you guys are pod
listeners gym glass I see you down there
we'll get to your question next time
Andrew rich you guys gotta come out it's
the coolest thing I mean and just the
way everyone is the community like last
year you were doing the periscope like
that was really cool we had some tech
issues and you jumped in and and people
love that and I just loved the whole
community of it and if your podcast
listener it's the greatest weekend
you're ever gonna happen I'm not
bullshitting you at all like yeah it's
so much fun it's a weekend of not having
to go explain what a podcast is to
anybody it's a weekend of everyone
getting you yeah like I've had so many
people go I felt like an outsider my
whole life until I came like so many
people so yeah so stick around for
updates on pod fest odder still woman I
think should be banned from the festival
oh she's so annoying she is so annoying
alright sorry going she's there every
year but god she's annoying uh if you're
a podcast listener then you're a comedy
nerd generally speaking if you're a
comedy podcast at a kid in a stand-up
show right shut up yeah shut up and
laugh that's all you have to tell you
gotta do it's not hard she shouldn't
come back yeah so Murray's talking about
Kira's all time I know so yeah check
those things out earbuds a pod fast and
awesome film nerds and my tour dates
Graham at grand mal would check all that
out excellent and I am of course at
Marie V on twitter i just put up a ton
of dates for the summer at marie yeah i
got some new dates coming up
oh the idol slavia little slow I me in
tahoe Marge second through oh I don't
have a question I have is timing a
factor when it comes to comedy Graham
you want to answer that I will be
headlining the skyline comedy cafe in
appleton wisconsin March 17 through 19
so how many tickets i sell is important
if you live in the fox valley buy a
ticket yes where are we at murphy on
twitter marie valeriano calm write a
review on iTunes if you haven't you
haven't done that in a while we had a
couple new ones up there that's always
great gives it a little boost on the
other thing I know what else should I
ask him for as a podcast guy if a review
what else you know the thing we say on
comedy film nerds as we say vote with
your dollars mm-hmm I mean we have an
online store so we say spend twenty
dollars with us once a year and then can
keep us afloat so if there's a way to
spend twenty dollars with marie knew it
okay um and the these things might not
seem like they're big but they are
because everyone's tracking data and
numbers so how many followers murray has
how many positive reviews of the road
stories all those clicks likes follows
those all add up hmm and that's those
are free ways you can help support this
podcast every free free i'm talking to
you people who haven't like this on the
facebook page like the facebook page
don't be a douche share it on whatever
social media you're on hey guys listen
to this yeah tell your friends about
like those little things you have no
idea how much they help there's there's
comedy clubs booking you based on the
number of Twitter followers you have
that direct that that directly links to
ticket sales there's TV shows are you
kidding yeah executives Netflix yeah
network executives agents you know if if
Murray if you or I had a hundred
thousand Twitter followers or more it's
it's a lot hell of a lot easier to get a
meeting oh yeah definitely hit your show
to get an agent all that [ __ ] so all
those things help guys yeah grandma
would thank you so much I appreciate it
expand its always good hanging out with
you and we'll hit the surf when you get
back into town you got it I thanks guys
for listening come see Graham when he
comes to your town he's very funny thank
you at Murray beyond player
life on the road it's taco dangling or
strippers waiting guns and these fights
get the flights running with the runs
don't blacklists bounced checks great a
bachelorette bumps in the front making
out for your side and middle likes doing
ball more missing merge turn drive the
rental car has another mega church and
juice keys vagina fisted cell phone is
gone one big law and order